[MUSIC]
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
Hello, everyone.
My name is Jarek Wiliewicz.
Welcome to YouTube
Developers Live.
We have an exciting show
for you today.
Let me first introduce
our hosts and guests.
In the studio, I have
Jeremy Walker.
JEREMY WALKER: All right.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: How are
you doing, Jeremy?
JEREMY WALKER: I'm
doing great.
I'm doing good.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I hear you've
been traveling lately.
JEREMY WALKER: Yep.
I've been gone in Brazil for the
last seven to eight days.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: What were
you doing in Brazil?
JEREMY WALKER: I was
going around
promoting the YouTube APIs.
So I went to a bunch
of cities--
Sao Paulo, Belo Horizonte.
And I talked to a lot of
developer groups about using
the YouTube APIs.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Are you going
to show us any samba
moves later on in this
broadcast that you
picked up in Brazil?
JEREMY WALKER: I left those with
the drinking in Brazil.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Oh, I see.
Well, I am disappointed.
JEREMY WALKER: [CHUCKLING]
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All right.
Then we have Jeff Posnick
joining us live from New York.
How are you doing, Jeff?
JEFFREY POSNICK: I'm
doing very well.
Hopefully looking higher
quality today
than in previous weeks--
like full 720p right now.
And I hope it comes across.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Indeed.
I am told you are looking
fantastic today.
JEFFREY POSNICK: [CHUCKLING]
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All right.
And then let me introduce our
guests who have joined us from
Florida and Chicago,
I understand.
PHIL HARRIS: Yes.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Phil.
PHIL HARRIS: Hi.
I'm Phil Harris, CEO
of Geofeedia.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And Scott.
SCOTT MITCHELL: And Scott
Mitchell, CTO of Geofeedia.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All right--
and then, Scott,
you are based in--
SCOTT MITCHELL: Naples,
Florida--
sunny Naples, Florida.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Unlike the
rainy northern California?
SCOTT MITCHELL: Unlike
it is here.
We were hoping for some sunny
weather but instead got some
rain, but not so bad.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I like the
rain here in the winter.
I think otherwise the downside
is drought in the summer.
And then, Phil, you
live in Chicago?
PHIL HARRIS: In Chicago.
And our business team
is gearing up for
a pretty cold winter.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All right.
So let's chat a little bit
about your product.
I wanted to start off with
a simple question.
What is the problem you're
trying to solve?
And then maybe get into how did
you come up with the idea.
PHIL HARRIS: Great.
Thanks, Jarek.
First of all, thank you
very much, Google,
for having us today.
Google's a wonderful partner,
and especially the YouTube
team-- so appreciate, Jeremy,
all the support.
Geofeedia provides social media
search and location
monitoring by physical
location.
We aggregate social media across
multiple different
social data sets to provide
businesses--
we're a business tool-- to
provide businesses insights
about what's happening at their
physical locations.
So any business, government
agency, or other group that
has a physical location would
find value in the
Geofeedia data set.
We aggregate data from many
different sources, YouTube
being one of them.
And unlike traditional social
media listening tools, which
are text-based--
keyword and hashtag based--
we incorporate lots of video,
imagery, to give businesses
not only a text-based repository
of data to mine,
but also imagery, imagery about
what's happening at
their restaurant, what's
happening at their store,
what's happening
at their event.
There's a saying, a picture
tells a thousand words.
Well, with Geofeedia,
you can quickly
assess what's happening.
So we provide a very different
way of looking at that social
media data set compared to the
traditional social media
listening tools, which are
keyword and hashtag-based.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Very
interesting.
So a picture is worth
a thousand words.
So how much is a video worth?
PHIL HARRIS: 10 times as much.
[CHUCKLING]
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: What about
video at 60 frames per second?
PHIL HARRIS: It's
worth way more.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
So very interesting.
So how did you come
up with the idea?
PHIL HARRIS: Well, we are
technology executives on the
technical side and the
business side.
And one of the complaints we
kept hearing from brand
managers and other purchasers
and users of social media
listening tools was that they
didn't find the data relevant
and actionable.
These tools aggregate
lots of data.
So the goal is to incorporate
as much data as possible.
And then the business would
get graphs and charts on
different things happening--
on aggregate volume.
When you really ask them
candidly if it's of use, they
say, well, we need to know
what's happening.
But very little of it is
actionable, meaning there's
things that, really, we
can take action on
and make use of.
What we're trying to do is
filter out the vast majority
of data and only collect
information happening at a
customer's physical location.
So that person has experienced
a retail experience, a brand
experience.
And we only collect
information from that location.
So it's much more contextual.
And what we're hearing is that
when a consumer visits a
store, for example, and
experiences it and then gives
feedback, the brand manager
is saying that's much more
valuable than someone who
never visited the store
commenting on the store.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah.
PHIL HARRIS: It's
very contextual.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So should we
take a look at a demo before
we drill into more of others?
PHIL HARRIS: I think
we should jump in.
And I'll turn it over to Scott
Mitchell, Geofeedia's CTO.
JEREMY WALKER: Scott,
you have the floor.
SCOTT MITCHELL: Let's
jump right in.
All right, so as Phil described,
Geofeedia is a
search by location tool.
So we allow you to locate a
position on a map and find
different tweets, pictures,
and videos that are within
that location.
Before I start the demo, I'll
preface it by saying we're
querying live real
public data.
So anything that we see
and the results.
It may get a little
goosy at times.
So this could get interesting.
Right here we can see on the
map view Geofeedia's main
interface for starting
a query.
So just like Google starts you
on their home page with a
search box to type in a keyword,
with Geofeedia, since
our searches are not
keyword-based, they're
location-based, we start
you with a map.
And in the most simple
form, users search
the map with a circle.
And the circle can be expanded,
contracted, and
shifted around the map.
And then the blue button there
in the middle of the circle
runs the query.
As this query's running, the
system is going out and
finding pictures from Instagram,
videos from
YouTube, photos from
Flickr, and tweets.
And it's only looking for
posts that are geotagged
within this area.
So we're filtering out, as Phil
said, a lot of the noise
that comes in regular searches
that users might do with
standard keyword or hashtag
queries for items that might
be in, say, Midtown Manhattan.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So I see
the query completed.
And then items that were found
are shown as those little
thumbnails on the map?
SCOTT MITCHELL: That's
correct.
There are pins located on the
map with their exact geotagged
location of where they were
posted by the user.
JEREMY WALKER: You can filter
sources, right?
SCOTT MITCHELL: Yep.
And right now we're showing by
default the first 100 or the
most recent 100 posts
in this area.
So you see a lot of tweets and
Instagram photos as the
primary activity.
But let's turn those off
and get down to--
maybe we're interested in just
looking at YouTube videos.
So I can easily turn off those
other sources and immediately
get to just the YouTube
videos that are within
this region as well.
And again, these are videos that
are geotagged at these
locations, some of which may
have been taken by users on
their mobile phone and uploaded
directly to YouTube
through their mobile phone.
Others may have been uploaded to
YouTube and then geotagged
through the YouTube.com
interface.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Is
there a temporal
dimension to this as well?
Can people request only recent
tweets or videos?
Or how does that work?
SCOTT MITCHELL: Yep.
There's also different ways to
filter the content and drill
down further than just
the sources.
And if we look at the date
filters here, we can query for
items that were posted between
a date range, before a
particular date range, or
after a particular date.
So we can get very granular
in terms of
date and source filtering.
And then also we have
the ability to
break the content down.
We can fine-tune it even more
by applying some x query
filters to the raw data.
That's an advanced feature.
But it lets users query on any
of the metadata that's tied to
these videos--
title, author, more on the
dates, descriptions.
Or any of the data that we get
back from the YouTube Atom
result, we can apply an x query
to the result and filter
the videos based on that.
JEREMY WALKER: And obviously,
when you click on one of
these, you can watch
the video.
Or with the other social
products, you can look at
pictures or whatever
that was posted.
SCOTT MITCHELL: So a couple
different ways to do that.
One is in this map view, we
can hover over the pins.
And we can see a description of
each item and a play button
that will play the video
right in line.
The other option to view this
data is to look at our collage
view, which is a
Pinterest-inspired view of the
data, if you will.
And let's just turn on some
Picasa photos here, too, so we
can see what it looks like
with photos and videos
interspersed together.
And in this view, is it's
a different way
to look at the data.
Instead of hovering around the
pins on the map, you can
consume it all at once
and scroll down.
You can see as we get to the
bottom of the page, it will
load more items in an infinite
scrolling manner.
So like I said, we're looking
at the most recent 100 in
reverse chronological order.
And it continues to
load farther and
farther back in time.
The nice thing about YouTube
and Picasa is that they've
been around for years
and years and years.
So we've seen data from both
these sources going back to
2006 that people are able
to find with our tool.
And that's useful for our
customers that are interested
in doing research at particular
areas, journalists
that are looking for information
from locations,
and also just any sort of
business intelligence that you
might need to apply.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So you
mentioned that the way you
present the data makes
it actionable.
So what are the typical actions
that the people take?
I mean, when I see this
Pinterest-like view, what are
the use cases?
And are you helping with
any of these to kind of
get to the next step?
PHIL HARRIS: Sure.
It depends on the
organization.
But it could be a customer
service related issue.
It could be in the area
of law enforcement.
There could be some criminal
activity that happens in a
certain location.
It could be some other
level of crisis,
like Hurricane Sandy.
We saw an extraordinary amount
of usage to help save people
that were stranded
in their houses.
So emergency responders
used it quite heavily.
So when something happens
at a place, this
is real-time activity--
real-time intelligence.
And because much of it is in
picture form, it does require
some level of judgment and
decision-making from an
individual.
But there are trends that we
look at to trigger people to
look at geographies depending
on activity-- depending on
certain things happening within
that geography as well
to alert them that there is
actually something that they
should look at right now.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I see.
You could look at some aggregate
metrics-- for
example, high number of videos
or tweets posted from a
specific area.
PHIL HARRIS: Absolutely.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: But with
respect to their content, this
is where the human comes into
the picture and they have
better judgment.
PHIL HARRIS: I think so.
And an example would be for
Hurricane Sandy, there was a
Picasa picture, I think, that
surfaced that said that the
86th Street subway terminal
had flooded.
There was only one image.
Nobody else was talking
about it.
With our tool, we drew a
geo-fence around that area.
There was nothing else.
If the 86th Street subway
terminal had flooded in
Manhattan, I think more than
one person would be
commenting on it.
So it ended up being false.
Someone had Photoshopped
something or
mocked up an imagery.
On the flip side, there was a
lot of activity from Point
Pleasant, New Jersey, claiming
on homes getting bombarded
with waves and whatnot.
And when you drew a geofeed,
which is what we call this
virtual perimeter around
a physical location.
Around Point Pleasant, New
Jersey, you could clearly see
that waves were literally
crashing into beachside homes
and destroying them.
And there was not just one.
There were dozens of them.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So it sounds
like this actually greatly
improves the quality
of the information.
PHIL HARRIS: Yes.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Interesting.
PHIL HARRIS: Because it's
all related to a place.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
Sorry I interrupted your train
of thought, Scott.
SCOTT MITCHELL: Great
questions.
When you see the tool in action
and actually start
using it, I think it conjures
up a whole set of thoughts
around, all right, I can get
this YouTube data and these
videos now by location in a way
that I couldn't before.
And it's interesting to search
by keyword and do that on
YouTube dot com and
through Google.
But it's also very interesting
to look at different places
that have some sort of intrigue
to you, whether it's
your alma mater or it's your
hometown or it's your favorite
vacation spot or if it's part
of your job, like Phil
mentioned for first responders,
crisis management,
even retail locations looking
to get some intelligence.
So no problem with
the questions.
So we'll flip again back
over to the map.
And the circle search is
one that we showed.
We also have the ability to
narrow down into a very
specific polygon.
So we can draw these complex
polygons and also search
within those.
There is no limit to the level
of detail you can get down to.
We can search within the
proximity of a phone booth, if
you need to.
We can also go out as wide
as five kilometers--
so flexible search
tools there.
And as Phil mentioned, too, we
talk about these as geofeeds.
So you have the area that you're
interested in, whether
its the circle or the polygon
or the square of the map.
Once you save that, you've
saved the geofeed.
And that geofeed can be viewed
in a few different ways.
One is on this map view,
along with the collage.
And you can see the
search results.
I can flip back over there.
Suppose that we're
a journalist.
And we're covering a particular
event that's
happened at this location.
It might not be reasonable to
expect the journalist to pull
up this geofeed and continue to
refresh the page to see the
most recent items that are
coming into this area.
So to solve that, we've also
built a bit of a different
view of a geofeed, which is
here that I'm showing.
This is our geo-streamer tool,
which streams the results of a
geofeed live to your desktop
through the browser.
So you can see now we're looking
at a little bit of a
different area on the map view
with different pins appearing
on the map.
And if I just collapse that map
view, since this is a very
active area, we'll see
new things pop in to
the top of this feed.
Again, back to that journalist
scenario.
Suppose you're covering a few
months back when it was the
shooting at the Empire
State Building.
And there were journalists
getting onto the tool and
searching within that vicinity
to see what live photos and
tweets were being posted from
people that were actually at
the location.
This is a very helpful
technology to get at that
right away.
They're already doing it with
tools like TweetDeck to see
the live streams
of information.
This complements that so that
they can look at it and pull
in data also from an area--
not just by keyword.
JEREMY WALKER: That's great.
SCOTT MITCHELL: So I'd also like
to get into some of the
ways that Geofeedia
leverages Google.
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah, I noticed
you had a couple extra tabs on
what you're actually using--
the YouTube APIs.
So you're using the version 2
of the Data API, correct?
SCOTT MITCHELL: That's right.
We're using YouTube's v2.0.
And particularly related to
that, we're using the location
search elements.
So you'll find this in the v2.0
documentation for the
video search.
I'm in that section
on this document.
And you'll see information on
how to use the location
element, the location
query parameter.
This parameter, we use it to
specify the radius of the
search area that we're looking
for around the particular
latitude, longitude that the
customer is looking at.
And then from there, we further
refine the results to
make sure that they only fit in
the exact polygon that the
user wants.
And then also, I should
mention--
I'm not sure if all developers
are even aware of this-- but
we do use the Google
Hosted Libraries.
You can search for
that on Google.
And you'll end up at this page
that shows the variety of
JavaScript libraries
that are hosted by
Google on Google servers.
We use jQuery.
We use the jQuery hosted
libraries.
So that's been great for us to
be able to offload that and
pull it very quickly.
Speed is something that's super
important to us in terms
of page-load times
for our users.
So we definitely like to offload
as much of that from
our servers as possible.
Google provides one way
to do that for us.
And then also, Google-inspired
technology that we've built
comes in the form of portability
for our geofeeds.
So we talked about being able to
search and see the results
in the collage on the map,
being able to stream.
We also have APIs around
these geofeeds as well.
And these were, like I said,
inspired by Google's, YouTube,
and Picasa APIs, where we
decided our geofeeds should be
portable in an RSS
and Atom format.
So we've been able to build
output methods that with the
same URL requests, we can
respond with an Atom response.
And it's formatted as GeoRSS.
So if you take that Atom
response and actually just
dump it into a Google map
like we've done here--
all I've done in this Google
Maps screen is put the URL to
our Atom feed in the
search box there.
And you can see how Google
Maps shows--
JEREMY WALKER: Just hit back.
I think we hit the microphone,
so it thought--
SCOTT MITCHELL: Oh.
JEREMY WALKER: Now
just hit forward.
We'll try that again.
I think the microphone thought
you were trying
to search on that.
So yeah, there we go.
SCOTT MITCHELL: I'll pull
it back up here.
So Google Maps shows our feeds
just as you would see them in
the map view on Geofeedia.
And then also I know version 3.0
of the YouTube API's out
there in experimental mode and
looking at things like JSON as
a response format.
And we've done the same thing
as well with our geofeeds to
make them accessible through
APIs in JSON format so that
they can be consumed very easily
on the JavaScript side.
JEREMY WALKER: So I take it you
guys haven't messed around
yet with the version
3.0 of the APIs.
SCOTT MITCHELL: No.
We would like to
get into that.
There's some things that we've
talked about that are
attractive to us, especially the
JSON formatting and also
the ability to specify what
gets returned back in the
response from Google so that
we can optimize the payload
and the speed at which
we can process that.
We want to minimize as much as
possible the amount of data
going across the wire and
the amount of data
that we need to process.
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah.
SCOTT MITCHELL: So the features
of v3.0 that allow us
to only get back the elements
in the nodes that we need in
that payload is something
that's very attractive.
So we'll be looking at that
as soon as you tell me
it's ready to go.
JEREMY WALKER: OK.
[CHUCKLING]
I'm curious, what are you guys
using on the back end to
handle all of this?
SCOTT MITCHELL: We are, I'll
say, a 90% Microsoft stack.
JEREMY WALKER: OK.
SCOTT MITCHELL: So we have a
host of servers in the cloud
that we run Microsoft
ASP.NET, MVC.
SQL Server is the back
end database.
The other percentage of our
stack that is not Microsoft
runs on Linux, uses RabbitMQ
for very high speed, high
throughput, highly available
queuing system.
As you can imagine with the
streamer, getting thousands
and tens of thousands of people
streaming content at
one time is a solution that is
very difficult to scale to.
So we needed that
availability.
And we went away from
Microsoft for that.
That's working well.
And then we're also looking at
Cassandra as a way to handle
much bigger data than
we are today.
So that's farther out
in our future.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
So I'm curious.
Was there anything you've ran
into that surprised you when
you were using our APIs that
you could share with us in
your experiences?
SCOTT MITCHELL: Yes.
We love Google technologies.
We're fully baked into Google
Apps as a company,
using that and Gmail.
But it's not just because
we like Google.
We would like the response.
We like the speed.
We like the durability
of it all.
So I couldn't think of a way to
really convey that except
to show the results that we see
between the YouTube and
the Picasa APIs and the other
APIs that we use our system.
So we constantly monitor the
response times on those API
calls that we make
to retrieve data.
And I've graphed those
out here over time.
And you can see that the YouTube
response times are
very consistent.
There are some peaks
and valleys there.
But for the most part, those
are very bearable for
systems like ours.
And they range around
the 300 to 400
millisecond range there.
Picasa's a little bit higher
but equally consistent.
And you can see the other APIs
in the gray are not nearly as
consistent and four to
five times slower.
So going into this, we didn't
know what to expect in terms
of building a tool that mashed
up data from different APIs
and the response time that
we'd get on those.
But we were surprised to see
that YouTube and Picasa were
so consistent or so stable.
This chart doesn't show the
number of errors that each one
of these APIs returns.
But I can tell you that YouTube
and Picasa are an
order of magnitude, or more,
better than the other APIs
even in terms of their errors.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I think the
peaks correspond to various
videos going viral.
In fact, I think the last one
is Psy's "Gangnam Style."
SCOTT MITCHELL: Really?
I heard Jeremy knows
that dance.
Yeah, the mambo.
But he knows that one.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I just got
back from South Korea, so I
couldn't resist that comment.
[CHUCKLING]
JEREMY WALKER: Wow, that's
pretty neat.
I guess, do you have anything
you'd share with the audience
of people who are
going to start
integrating with the APIs?
Like any kernels that you could
throw to them that you
think they should think about
as they start their
integration?
SCOTT MITCHELL: I'd say the
documentation that we are
looking at before for the
YouTube API version 2.0.
Definitely spend the time
reading this, researching it,
looking at it, understanding
it.
It's very easy.
Google makes it very easy to
jump into an API, write a URL,
get your data back and
begin using it.
There's nuances, though, of
those APIs that can really
help you out, really help you
get to the exact data you
need, help you filter
your data.
And it seems to also be
something that is--
at least the documentation, I'm
not so sure about the back
end-- but it gets better
over time.
So it's not something that is
out there and is static and
never changes month
after month.
This documentation is this
constantly evolving.
So revisiting it.
Now I'm constantly going back
and looking at the location
query parameter usage and making
sure that we're doing
that and using the best
practices that Google
recommends.
So I think staying current
with the documentation,
reading it, and understanding
it before jumping
in is key to success.
JEREMY WALKER: Well, great.
Thanks for the demo and kind
of talking a little
bit about the API.
This is great stuff.
And it's really interesting
to see that graph.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And we'll
definitely pass our
documentation feedback to our
documentation guy, Andy.
JEREMY WALKER: He'll be happy to
know somebody's reading it.
[LAUGHING]
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah, we get
a lot of very good feedback
for the quality of his work.
All right, so should we
transition to Jeff's Stack
Overflow question
of the week now?
JEREMY WALKER: Sure.
Did you have anything else
you wanted to add?
I know we were talking
a little bit about
the technical side.
And we really dove into that.
But I just wanted to make sure
we didn't miss anything.
PHIL HARRIS: No, that's great.
I appreciate that.
What we're seeing is with the
proliferation of smart phones
that have geolocation services
combined with the app
developers, like YouTube and
Picasa, promoting geolocation
services within the application
environment.
We think that this
location-based data set will
become richer and richer
over time.
So we're very excited to work
with Google to make that a
reality and to provide
that richer
experience for our customers.
So we couldn't be more excited
about the trends, about the
power of social media.
Like all new destructive
technology, it's not perfect.
It requires a certain amount
of education on when to use
geolocation services and
when not to use it,
especially for children.
So we're just very, very excited
about working together
to make that data set richer
and richer and letting
consumers voices be heard
by businesses.
I think it's important point
here, is that if you're
experiencing something at a
McDonald's real-time, and you
express yourself either through
a video or through a
picture, wouldn't it be great
if you heard back from a
McDonald's person addressing
your complaint real-time while
you had that experience?
Even if it was a virtual type
complaint or maybe compliment
even, that real-time voice, I
think we allow that to be
amplified through.
Obviously we would be nowhere
if we didn't have the
underlying data set.
But provided we have the data
set, we can allow those
consumers' voices to be heard
more broadly by businesses.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And actually,
this reminds me of a
point that one of our guests
made on this show earlier.
Link TV, they were talking
about the paper that they
published about how people view
user generated media.
And I think that the key part
that appeals especially to
certain demographics, like
younger people, is the
authenticity of it.
PHIL HARRIS: Yes.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So I think
with your solution, you can
actually filter out the noise
by overlaying the geo
information on top of content
that may be coming from
sources that are not necessarily
authentic.
I mean, there could be bots
tweeting and things like that.
So I think that takes care of
actually filtering it out.
But then in and of itself,
I think the content is
considered authentic by people
who care about and therefore
should be more important to the
businesses that use it.
PHIL HARRIS: You bring up
an outstanding point.
There's a broad trend called
citizen journalism.
And in unprecedented ways,
YouTube, Picasa users can
express themselves with more
authenticity, with context
related to a place.
And that power makes it that
much more real for the
consumer of that information
because it's more authentic.
And it's more real.
And it's real time.
It's real time.
This is unprecedented
in human history.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All
right, great.
So I know Jeff has been getting
a little bored with us
doing all the talking out
in New York City.
Jeff, are you still there?
JEFFREY POSNICK: It's
interesting stuff, absolutely.
And very interesting stuff
about Geofeedia.
So I've been listening
intently.
And I'd be happy to talk about
the Stack Overflow question of
the week now.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
Let's go for it.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Cool.
So kind of one question I've
been engaging with mostly is
something about using what we,
I guess, now refer to as
legacy YouTube usernames within
version 3.0 of the API.
So folks are familiar with the
older version 1.0 or 2.0 of
the API probably know you can
construct a request URL using
gdata.youtube.co
m///googledevelopers.
And you can put the
Google Developers
username in the URL.
And you can get the uploads feed
for Google Developers,
things like that.
You can do that for any
YouTube username.
Version 3.0-- things are
a little different.
We don't actually accept legacy
YouTube usernames as
part of either the request URLs
or as part of the request
parameters anymore.
Everything is done via
these channel IDs.
Channel IDs work, I suppose, in
version 2.0 of the API, but
tended not to be used
quite as much.
So the question comes from
Mark Costello, a Stack
Overflow user.
And he just wanted to know
what's the best way of
translating from a legacy
YouTube username into a
channel ID that you can then
use with version 3.0.
This question was actually
answered by Matthias, who's
kind of one of our Google
Developer experts for YouTube.
So thank you, Matthias for
initially providing the
response there.
And basically what Matthias
said was doing a search.
You know, we now have universal
search in the
YouTube API starting
with version 3.0.
So you can search for channels
via the same
search dot list method.
And you can pass in that YouTube
username as one of the
parameters for the
query string.
And you'll get back
one or more--
like 0 or more--
channel resources showing
you all the
channels that match it.
So this kind of works
as you'd expect.
Although there is obviously
some catches.
You might pass in what you think
was a unique YouTube
username, or at least was a
unique YouTube username in
version 2.0.
And you might get multiple
results back when you're doing
this search in version 3.0
because you're not doing an
exact match, basically.
There could be multiple things
that you'll get.
Or alternatively, maybe you're
passing in a display name to
the search method.
And you're getting back multiple
results because there
happens to be a lot of people
who have the John Smith
display name as part of
their display name for
their channel now.
So you get back multiple
results
potentially in this case.
So you just need to be aware of
that potential for getting
multiple results.
We actually do have a feature
request in with the
engineering team to instead of
kind of do a search for any
sort of channel that matches a
string to let you pass in a
specific legacy username and
get back the one specific
channel that that corresponds to
in version 3.0 of the API.
I haven't actually heard back
from the engineering team if
that's going to be
implemented yet.
So I'm afraid we don't have a
better solution right now.
But you can definitely try to
do that search call from
version 3.0.
And hopefully, you'll get
something that works well
enough for you.
So that's pretty much what
I want to cover for that.
Definitely let us know about
any questions that you have
with version 3.0 of the data
API, any of the other YouTube
APIs on Stack Overflow.
I really like interacting
with folks there.
And just be sure that you're
tagging your question with
YouTube dash API when you
post on Stack Overflow.
And that way, our team
will see it.
And hopefully, we'll be able
to give you an answer.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
That's great.
JEFFREY POSNICK: That's
it for me.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Thank you
for covering the Stack
Overflow question of the week.
As always, Jeff, very
interesting stuff.
And then we just have a couple
of more minutes left.
So let's look at the
moderator to see
if we have any questions.
So I see one question that is
relevant from Jeremy Walker--
sounds familiar.
"Is YouTube Google Developer
relations hiring?" So I will
take a stab at that.
The answer is yes, we are
hiring, both YouTube and
Developer relations
as well as Google.
To find out more information,
go to
developers.google.com/jobs.
And you can see all the
different types of positions
that we have available.
And we definitely encourage
you to apply.
It's a fun team to work on.
Sometimes we get to do even more
stuff that is fun, like
traveling to Brazil
and dancing samba.
JEREMY WALKER: Yep.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: But we're
definitely looking for people
to join our team.
So I think this is
it for this week.
MALE SPEAKER: Actually, we have
some questions on YouTube
for the Geofeedia guests.
So there are questions around
Social Media for Good.
People are seeing that Geofeedia
is a process that
they can use to react to the
type of disasters, to work
with things like that.
How do you guys see Geofeedia
working with
Social Media for Good?
And how has that been related
to your story so far?
PHIL HARRIS: That's an
outstanding question.
Geofeedia is being used today
for emergency responders,
volunteer organizations, to help
provide relief, whether
it's just any humanitarian
effort.
So we feel really good about
our providing data to those
organizations like FEMA, Red
Cross, all across the EU,
third world countries,
et cetera.
One of the issues with emergency
responders is where
do you allocate your
resources?
What areas are most impacted?
And minutes, hours, can mean
life or death for some people
who are impacted.
They might not have
clean water.
They might be stranded
in a house.
So anything we can do to get
our tool into the hands of
humanitarian organizations,
relief organizations, is a big
win for us.
So we were in Washington, DC
recently at the World Bank for
a presentation on
crisis response.
And we had worldwide
organizations there
looking on the tool.
And we're happy to say that
it's being utilized in
real-time events like Hurricane
Sandy and other
situations around the globe.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
Any other questions coming in
from the YouTube audience?
MALE SPEAKER: We
have feedback.
People love Geofeedia and
what they're doing.
But beyond that, no additional
questions.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: OK, great.
PHIL HARRIS: I guess I have
one more comment.
If you'd like a Geofeedia trial
account, you can go to
geofeedia.com and
request a trial.
We are coming up on our
two year anniversary.
But most of that time, frankly,
has been Scott and
his team in a dark cave coding
and working on building what
you saw today.
So we commercially launched the
product earlier this year.
And we've been overwhelmed
by the response.
But we realize businesses and
relief organizations can do
great things to hear
the consumer voice.
So if you have an interest in
our product, we'd be happy to
issue you a trial account.
And of course, you can access
all that great YouTube
video-rich content in there and
Picasa imagery in there.
So we're very excited to
have you as a partner.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
Thank you very much.
I hope you will give
preference to the
viewers of this show.
[CHUCKLING]
PHIL HARRIS: Absolutely.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All right,
so let me try that again.
I think this is it.
[LAUGHING]
PHIL HARRIS: Sorry.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And we'll see
you again next week, same
place, same time, 10:00
AM Pacific.
Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you all.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Bye.
[MUSIC]